la forteresse de chinon et le sable de
la vienne un décor de carte postale pour
ce 26e tournoi de beach volley chinonais
le rendez vous de l'été pour ces quatre
amis depuis six ans et la fin du lycée
elle se retrouve ici de temps d'une
journée dans une ambiance bon enfant
malgré l'adversité
cette année on est clean féminine alors
qu'avant il y avait un tournoi spécial
féminin quoi donc un peu déçu mais enfin
ça se bat bien quand même
les gars sont gentils nous laisse le
service de départ une défaite pour ce
premier match mais pas de quoi perdre le
sourire en appel que si ridicule que ça
leur va comme elle
21 équipes amateurs s'affrontent dans
différentes poules cette année neuf
équipes de licencier des joueurs qui
évoluent au niveau régional voire
national comme cédric da silva ce
passeur a commencé le volley ball à
orléans à l'âge de 12 ans après deux
saisons à orange direction le club de
danse y en pro b ce tournoi un bon
compromis avant la reprise
je garde le rythme on montre en
m'entraînant quotidiennement ça permet
un peu de toucher la balle de faire un
petit tournoi tranquille
même s'il n'ya pas d'enjeu moi je viens
juste pour m'amuser pour toucher un peu
le ballon voilà cédric da silva seul
joueur pro d'un tournoi où de nombreuses
têtes d'affiché the death affrontés
auparavant
de quoi attirer des amateurs avec trente
équipes cette année le tournoi est en
perte de vitesse mais les organisateurs
ne désespèrent pas de retrouver leur
belle saison
il ya une quinzaine d'années oui on
était monté à 70 équipes c'était le taux
le plus fort bond c'est aussi des
grosses années c'est vrai que le sport
associatif
un peu en deçà actuellement voilà c'est
un objectif et jf nous déjà pour le club
quarante à cinquante équipes c'est
superbe pour relancer le tournoi en 2019
une piste est privilégiée des marchés
des joueurs du club tours volley ball
pour un match exhibition
[Musique]